us is in a recession at the moment but
it's not allowed to be called recession
well the government's trying to not call
it a recession but it's Wikipedia
article
got changed you see this really oh dude
no so they redefined recession yep so
recession used to be two consecutive
quarters of negative GDP growth right
not anymore not on Wikipedia in the
White House Press Secretary Define the
economy as being strong and the the best
economy we've had in over a decade have
you seen her do that no it's hilarious
it's like the wildest gaslighting
because she's doing all of these
political hand Maneuvers that people do
you know those moves that people do with
their hands when they're talking and
they're trying to display like
confidence and control and there's like
it's it's literally like political
pantomiming they're literally changing
the definition which is terrible and it
should be pushed back against in a big
way